but what's like one thing about dave
that you think
uh people would be surprised to know
about him man
that he doesn't eat fruits and
vegetables he doesn't eat fruits and
vegetables doesn't eat fruits and
vegetables at all
so what does he eat just meat he has a
diet
but he just definitely doesn't like
fruits and vegetables that's a real
fact too it's like people would be
surprised like you don't eat fruits
bananas apples pears nothing no veggies
no veggies no lettuce no onions no
tomatoes nothing so like what does he
eat for dinner
he like a lot of salmon a lot of chicken
you know i mean
pasta but what's on the side mac and
cheese
potatoes potatoes but he don't really
really don't eat no fruits and
vegetables i'll tell you that's a
surprising fact
what the hell crazy right is that like
known as something is there a name for
that
i have no idea but you told me to tell
you something surprising wow no fruits
and vegetables for
for dickie man that is surprise you eat
fruits and vegetables obviously
oh yeah definitely yeah i gotta have my
greens man gotta have my greens well go
follow tell everybody how to get at you
on instagram twitter all that man make
sure y'all get at me on
instagram ged gator get at me on twitter
get a ged you know what i'm saying
doing my thing grinding every day new
music out right now check out shout out
my boy blue that k
my guy there it is man it's the bootleg
cab show